Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about language
learning edge number five and that is
let go of your ego.
So what do I mean by ego?
Well,
by ego I mean that you have an image in
mind of the way you are and an image of
the way that you want other people to
see you.
In order to be successful in language
learning and really to be successful at
anything,
it's really important that you don't
cling too tightly to your image of
yourself.
It's important that you realize that
your image of yourself may not
completely be reality.
Basically,
you need to allow yourself to be
vulnerable.
You can't hide yourself from situations
that challenge your image of who you
are.
It's human nature to always look for
information that supports our image of
who we are.
But in order to grow as a person,
you need to be flexible in that self
image,
the way you see yourself.
Let me give you one example of how your
ego may trap you.
In this example,
you have convinced yourself that you
suck.
Let's say that you've had a bad
experience with language learning when
you were in school.
Maybe you had a bad teacher,
maybe nobody taught you how to study at
home.
Maybe you were just a teenager,
preoccupied with teenagers stuff,
but you concluded that you were bad with
languages.
You defined yourself as someone who was
not good with languages because you've
defined yourself as someone who was bad
with languages.
You have probably ignored evidence that
you can be good at them.
Maybe you started to get some success
with the language,
but you gave up and you didn't know why,
or maybe you had some success,
but you gave the thanks to some external
factor to someone else or something
else,
so that's success didn't motivate you.
Maybe every time you had a little
setback,
which everybody has,
you thought to yourself,
of course I have a setback.
I'm bad with languages.
This is my fault.
Maybe that unconscious belief about
yourself keeps you in a trance and you
need to snap out of it and see yourself
more objectively.
Recognize your successes and also know
that all successful people encounter
lots of challenges and failures.
Failures and successes did not define
you.
They're just something that everybody
goes through while learning a skill.
So I want you to evaluate your own
beliefs about yourself.
If you define yourself as someone who
has bad with languages,
expelled that belief from your mind
expelled that idea from yourself.
Here's another example of how your ego
can trap you.
In this example,
you are trying to convince yourself and
trying to convince other people that you
are amazing.
So let's say that you see yourself as
someone who is great with languages or
as someone who is great at everything,
we're better than other people at most
things he does,
and you present that image to other
people like you want them to believe
that,
well now you're trapped in that image as
being someone who's really good.
Now that might hurt your progress
because in order to improve,
you have to take risks.
You have to face failures,
you have to overcome challenges,
but if you are scared to shatter that
perfect image of yourself,
then you're probably going to refrain
from doing that.
You'll shy away from all of those risky
experiences because you want to see
yourself and you want other people to
see you as already perfect.
Taking risks,
making mistakes,
overcoming failure,
dealing with embarrassment.
That is all part of the learning process
for everyone,
and if you try to skip that part of the
learning process,
you will not be successful.
You may have noticed that I never
referred to myself as a polyglot and
there's a reason for that.
It's because I think that using that
word,
this is just me personally,
I'm not judging anyone else,
but when I use that word for myself,
I feel like that's creating an ego that
I have to be attached to.
Maybe if I call myself a polyglot than I
will be scared to speak a language in
front of other people.
If I'm not fluent in it yet,
maybe I'll be worried that I'm being
judged for my language skills,
so I'll want to speak less.
I tried to avoid that kind of go a trap
by not defining myself in terms of my
results.
I'm not a polyglot or I'm not someone
who is amazing with languages.
I'm just someone who loves languages and
loves the learning process.
So in order to free yourself from any
kind of self sabotage when it comes to
learning languages,
I recommend that you take a look at the
way you define yourself in terms of
language,
learning your story about yourself,
make sure that your story doesn't define
you as someone who was bad with
languages,
but on the other hand,
make sure that your story doesn't define
you as someone who is great with
languages.
Just define yourself as someone who can
get the right result by taking the right
action and dealing with all the little
challenges along the way.
No more,
no less.
Thank you for watching the [inaudible]
folks channel.
Please leave your comments down below
and I'll talk to you again.
Sure.